just hearing there from Akash there's
three options really although there
could be more but I mean the three main
points are yes they agree with the
Scottish Parliament and there can be
um another referendum uh secondly
absolutely not unless Westminster agrees
and thirdly
um well we'll have to send it back to
Scotland because there isn't enough for
us to judge on at this stage is that
about right yes that's a pretty good
summary I would say Okay fantastic Joe
is also with us outside the Supreme
Court and we'll bring him in in just a
moment Connor's standing by for us as
well up at holyrood
um how long will the Judgment be quite
short
it's um hard to say exactly I mean they
reached the decision sooner than we
might have expected actually just six
weeks or so after the the hearings when
we thought it might might take a few
months so that might be an indication
that in the end the court has found this
a simpler issue to to resolve so it
might be um just a relatively short
judgment okay and if it's kicked back
does that mean they can come again or
not
well yes so there is a possibility that
the Scottish government could could try
and pass the legislation
um
anyway if the the court essentially in
in the way we've just discussed
declines to answer the substantive
question and leaves it still in this
sort of let's have a quick listen Sherry
because the judges are coming in now so
let's hear what they um have to say will
there be an indie ref 2 in October of
next year
at the outset I should say that we are
pleased that the court has been able to
give judgment within a shorter time than
I had indicated might be necessary
that's partly because the court is
unanimous which considerably shortens
the time required and partly because the
Judgment has been prioritized over less
urgent matters
this is a brief explanation of the
Judgment handed down this morning
the four reasons for the Court's
decision will are set out in the
Judgment itself
the Scottish Parliament was established
by the United Kingdom Parliament at
Westminster in 1998 when it enacted the
Scotland Act
the Scotland act gives the Scottish
Parliament limited powers
in particular the Scottish Parliament
has no power to legislate in relation to
matters that are reserved to the United
Kingdom Parliament at Westminster
those reserved matters include
fundamental aspects of the Constitution
of the United Kingdom
including the union of Scotland and
England
and the United Kingdom Parliament
accordingly if legislation would relate
to the union or to the Westminster
Parliament
then the Scottish Parliament has no
power to enact it
foreign
on Scottish independence was held in
2014
an order in council had been made under
Section 30 of the Scotland act so as to
enable the Scottish Parliament to enact
the necessary legislation
the order in council amended the
definition of reserved matters
in the Scotland Act
by providing that the reservations of
constitutional matters including the
union and the United Kingdom Parliament
were not to apply to the 2014 referendum
legislation
the present case arises because the
Scottish government would like to
introduce a bill into the Scottish
Parliament which would provide for
another referendum on Independence
but the United Kingdom government is
unwilling to agree to the making of
another order in council under Section
30 at the present time
so in those circumstances the Scottish
government wishes if possible to hold a
referendum without an order in council
and therefore without any modification
of the definition of reserved matters
a lord Advocate who is the senior law
officer in the Scottish government
has asked this court for a ruling on the
question whether the proposed bill would
relate to reserved matters and therefore
be outside the powers of the Scottish
Parliament
The Advocate General for Scotland who is
the Scottish law officer in the United
Kingdom government
us after court not to decide the
question on the basis that it does not
fall within the scope of the procedure
for referring questions to this court
or alternatively on the basis that the
court should decline to decide the
question in the exercise of its
discretion
the court is not asked and cannot be
asked to express a view on the political
question of whether Scotland should
become an independent country
its task is solely to interpret the
relevant provisions of the Scotland act
and decide whether the proposed bill
would relate to reserved matters
the court has decided that it does have
the power to decide the question
referred to it by the Lord advocate
essentially the court has interpreted
the relevant Provisions according to the
ordinary meaning of words used and has
decided on that basis that the
provisions are wide enough to include
this reference by the Lord advocate
it's also consistent with the rule of
law that the Lord Advocate should be
able to obtain an authoritative judicial
decision on the legislative competence
of the Scottish parliament in advance of
the introduction of a bill
the court also accepts the Lord
advocate's argument that it is in the
public interest that the court should
decide the question referred to it
the reference has been made in order to
obtain an authoritative ruling on a
question of law which has already Arisen
on a matter of public importance
the Court's answer will determine
whether the proposed bill is introduced
into the Scottish Parliament
the reference is not therefore
hypothetical or premature
[Music]
turning to the question itself
the answer turns on whether the
provision of the proposed bill which
provides for a referendum on Scottish
independence would relate to matters
which have been reserved to the United
Kingdom Parliament
the Scotland act requires that question
to be determined by reference to the
purpose of the provision having regard
among other things to its effect in all
the circumstances
previous decision
establish that a provision will relate
to a reserved matter if it has something
more than a loose or consequential
connection with it
the purpose and effect of the provision
may be derived from a consideration of
both the purpose of those introducing
the legislation and the objective effect
of the legislation
its effect is not restricted to its
legal consequences but can include its
practical consequences
applying that test the reserve matters
which are relevant here are the union of
the kingdoms of Scotland and England
and the Parliament of the United Kingdom
the latter reservation has previously
been held to include the sovereignty of
the United Kingdom Parliament
the purpose of the proposed bill is to
hold a lawful referendum on the question
of whether Scotland should become an
independent country
that is on ending the Union
and ending the sovereignty of the United
Kingdom parliament in relation to
Scotland
the argument presented to the court by
the Lord Advocate but the proposed Bill
does not relate to reserved matters is
essentially that because the referendum
result would not automatically or
directly bring about the end of a union
it follows but Lee legislation does not
relate to the union
and because the referendum result would
not automatically or directly bring
about the end of the United Kingdom
Parliament sovereignty in relation to
Scotland therefore the proposed Bill
does not relate to the United Kingdom
Parliament
however as already explained the effects
of legislation for the purpose of
deciding whether it relates to a
reserved matter are not confined to its
legal effects but include its practical
effects
a lawfully held referendum would have
important political consequences
relating to the union and the United
Kingdom Parliament
its outcome would possess the authority
in the Constitution and political
culture founded upon democracy of a
democratic expression of the view of the
Scottish electorate
it would either strengthen or weaken the
Democratic legitimacy of a union and of
the United Kingdom's parliament's
sovereignty over Scotland depending on
which view prevailed
and it would either support or undermine
the Democratic credentials of the
independence movement
it's therefore clear that the proposed
bill has more than a loose or
consequential connection with the
reserve matters of the Union of Scotland
and England and the sovereignty of the
United Kingdom Parliament
foreign
National party which the court permitted
to intervene in the proceedings made
further submissions based primarily on
the right to self-determination in
international law
they argue in summary that the
limitations upon the powers of a
Scottish Parliament as laid down in the
Scotland Act
should be restrictively interpreted in a
way which is compatible with that right
to self-determination under
international law
the court is unable to accept that
argument
the SNP rely on the Judgment of the
Canadian Supreme Court in a case
concerned with Quebec
but in that case the Court held that the
right to self-determination under
international law only exists in
situations of former colonies
or where a people is oppressed as for
example under a foreign military
occupation
or were a definable group is denied
meaningful access to government to
pursue their political economic cultural
and Social Development
the court found that Quebec did not meet
the threshold of a colonial people or an
oppressed people
nor could it be suggested that quebecers
were denied meaningful access to
government to pursue their political
economic cultural and Social Development
the same is true of Scotland and the
people of Scotland
the SNP also relied on the submissions
of the United Kingdom government to the
international court of justice in a case
concerned with Kosovo
but those submissions are consistent
with the Quebec case
for government submitted that the right
to self-determination under
international law was normally limited
to situations of a colonial type or
those involving foreign occupation
that's not the position in Scotland
for all these reasons which are set out
more fully in the Judgment of the Court
unanimously concludes that the proposed
Bill does relate to reserved matters
accordingly in the absence of any
modification of a definition of reserved
matters
by an order in council under Section 30
of the Scotland act or otherwise
the Scottish Parliament does not have
the power to legislate for a referendum
on Scottish independence
okay quick uh snap analysis 30 seconds
from Akash who's been with us in the
studio thoughts
that's a very clear unanimous as the as
the president stated uh decision that
the referendum as proposed by Scottish
government cannot go ahead this now gets
kicked back into the the political Arena
I suspect okay Conor is with us at
holyrood uh no Indie ref two next
October Connor
this is uh probably the biggest
political uh constitutional moment here
in Scotland in very many years and let
me just remind you the main points of
what Lord read the president of the
Supreme Court said there he said this
was a unanimous uh judgment it was in
the public interest to make this ruling
uh which was the Scottish government's
argument all along here and they were
dealing only with the legal consequences
of this he says it was not hypothetical
it was not premature as the UK
Government tried to argue in that court
case last month in London to make a
ruling on this and he also recognized
that while there's legal ruling today is
strictly on a legal basis it does have
wider ramifications that of course head
into the political sphere but he was
absolutely clear unanimous Lord Reid
said that it does meet the test of being
a reserve matter and in that case the
Scottish Parliament here behind me does
not have the Paris allegedly it for a
second Scottish independence referendum
this is a big blow to First Minister
Nicholas sturgeon's case for holding a
second vote on the 19th of October next
year that was the plan of attack from
the Scottish national party and from the
Scottish government of course who have
won every election north of the Border
here in recent years standing on that
basis that they would be pursuing a
second vote so this will be a blow I
don't think it will be entirely
unsurprising because the Lord Advocate
herself who is the top law officer law
advisor to the Scottish government said
that she couldn't make this ruling and
that is why it was sent to the Supreme
Court so they're probably not entirely
surprising however it will be
disappointing for Nicholas sturgeon and
her Scottish government what happens
next is absolutely crystal uh is
absolutely
um you know one to be determined in the
coming hours Nicholas sturgeon has been
seeing all along that if the court made
this judgment that it was not within the
competence of Hollywood here to rule on
that then she would use the next general
election as a de facto Independence
referendum now Paul opposition
politicians have been saying that they
would not go along with that they would
not play ball with that so it'd be very
interesting to see in the coming hours
what exactly both sides of this debate
have to say because this Independence
question whatever way you come down on
the issue whether it's yes no unionist
or nationalist is absolutely through
every aspect of issues that are debated
here at Hollywood whether it be the
National Health Service whether it be
the Education Service the issues on both
sides are intertwined and it will be
very interesting to see exactly what
happens in the coming hours but a clear
a crystal clear argument and case there
from the Supreme Court that Hollywood
does not have the power to legislate for
a second Scottish independence
referendum without westminster's consent
stand by Connor if you were to cash
still with us here in the studio
suggestions there as we heard from
Connor that the next general election
could be a referendum on Independence
would that be legal
I mean I think it's not a question of
whether it's legal it's a question of
whether it's whether that has any
meaning Nicola sturgeon yes back in June
when
they the Scottish government published
its plans said that if they lost the
case
um the s p would fight the next election
as a de facto referendum but that's just
a piece of political rhetoric I mean a
UK general election is an election to
determine the membership of the House of
Commons to determine which part of your
parties forms the government of the
United Kingdom one political party
claiming that it is a referendum on a
particular issue does not change the
Constitutional fact of what a general
election is um so Connor that's what we
might hear from Nicola sturgeon later on
but a general election is to elect
people to the Chamber of the House of
Commons and and she just can't make it
into a referendum just because on
Independence just because she wants to
at Nicholas sturgeon's counter argument
to that point K would be that she has
stood on a platform where every single
election over the course of the last
couple of years on the basis that she's
asking people to vote for a party who
are standing on a platform of
Independence and she will argue in the
coming hours no doubt that if the court
is saying on a legal basis that this
place Hollywood cannot legislate for a
second Scottish independence referendum
and you've got a situation where the
prime minister's successive Prime
Ministers Boris Johnson Liz truss and
most recently Rishi sunak are saying
look now is not the time for that second
Independence referendum then what is the
Democratic route for Scotland to decide
its future because the majority of msps
in this place uh were elected on the
basis that they want an independence
referendum so this will trigger yet more
political debate more political row and
really we're no further forward after
that very Crystal Clear ruling from the
Supreme Court indeed so Joe Park is
outside the court for us now I mean it
seemed pretty clear-cut from the moment
Lord Reed sat down that this is what he
was going to say uh Joe what did you
think
[Music]
I think there will be a relief perhaps
on both sides that the first uh hurdle
was clear that that actually the court
could decide on the substantive issue of
whether the Hollywood Parliament can
have a referendum without westminster's
approval I think there will be relief
and Delight in the Scotland office and
in number 10 Richard sunac has been
paying close close attention to that and
part of his preparation for prime
minister's question today has been
getting an answer on the issue of
Scotland trying to get the tone right
and not to as some unionists would worry
let this moment become a moment of
momentum of galvanizing support for
Scottish independence for the SMP there
is an opportunity here for the SNP even
though they have lost I think on the SMP
side for Nicholas sturgeon for the
Scottish government it is difficult to
work out where next it is a a clear
setback yes she's talked about using the
next UK general election as a day back
to a referendum of Scottish independence
but within her party a lot of people who
don't think that's a great idea because
they think it's possible she will not
get a 50 of the the vote so a
consequential clear decision for the
Supreme Court it means that we're not
going to have another hearing here in a
year or two's time it's not going to be
sort of uh wrangling again and again and
again this is settle settled for now the
route to getting Scottish independence
now seems pretty unclear and that the s
p argue is unfair there should be a
mechanism especially of support for
Independence grows but I think a victory
today for the UK government that they K
will be very relieved about
okay Joe and Connor thanks very much
indeed a final thought from our
Devolution and Independence expert Akash
pound um is there any point in the
Scottish government appealing this
decision
there isn't any route to appeal the
Supreme Court has has made its decision
it's made it very clearly there's no
there's no higher Court to which this
issue can can now be taken so unless the
UK government UK Parliament at some
point accepts the Democratic case that
Scotland should have a referendum and
passes the necessary legislation as your
correspondents have just just pointed
out it's quite hard to see what the
route ahead will be for the SNP okay
thanks so much India for your expertise
thank you so tuning our way let me tell
you that there will not be a Scottish
independence referendum next October has
has been hoped by Nicola sturgeon she
says okay if that's the case when the
next election comes whenever that might
be I will use that as an independence
referendum we're just hearing from our
experts here she can say what she wants
that's not going to be the case Ian I
wonder whether that's going to have any
impact on the markets this morning good
morning to you thank you Kay well I
think that uh remains to be seen but in
the meantime welcome to wean King live
in our business and economic news from
the Heart of the City and we begin this
morning with the latest PMI data which
has been published in the last half hour
it's one of the more reliable indicators
of the state of the economy and it shows
that UK economic activity continued to
contract in November as orders decreased
and employment growth slowed or with any
reading above 50 representing growth and
any reading below that account